human fat, whose goal is to escape the pit
and take the place of their counterpart.
Picture this – if you’ll excuse that foreshadowing
pun: you’re at your local city mall in Ohio,
a place that’s never still.
Every time you go there, no matter what time
of day or day of the week, it’s always full
of people, all bustling about, shopping, eating,
dashing past one another.
Maybe, presumably like everyone else, you
came in to get some specific item.
Or you might be just browsing.
Heck, you could be there for a casual date,
or to grab a bite to eat at the food court.
That’s when you remember, you need to have
your picture taken.
It could be your passport is about to expire,
or your driver’s license hasn’t been updated
since you moved.
Whatever the reason, lucky for you there’s
a photo booth right here in the mall.
‘Take Your Own Photo’ boasts the sign
on the outside of the cramped cubicle, a list
of instructions below describing just how
quick and easy the process is.
You take a look at the price list, feed the
right amount of money into the slot, and take
a seat inside.
Pulling the curtain closed, you straighten
your back, looking directly into the lens.
A short countdown appears on the screen; three…
two… one.
A flash bursts from the bulb above the lens,
filling the booth, and leaving those white
spots floating in your vision for a few moments.
You head back out of the cubicle, waiting
to pick up the glossy paper with your photos
on it as it starts rapidly printing them off.
You wanted a two-by-two, four total pictures
of your face.
But then, as it finishes printing and you
inspect the pictures, turning the paper in
your hands, you’re met with a surprise…
an unnerving one to say the least.
The pictures don’t show your face, in fact,
it barely looks like a human face at all.
It has your clothes, and your hair, but the
whole image has been warped.
Not just out of focus, but completely disproportional.
Annoyed that you spent your money only to
receive a highly distorted image, you wander
off to find another booth, throwing the unusable
picture in the nearest trash can.
Now, sure, you might write off something like
that as just an odd occurrence, a freak of
technology caused by faulty machinery in desperate
need of repair.
But what you don’t know – in fact, you
won’t even realize until it’s too late
– is what really just happened.
When you sat down and that flash went off,
taking your picture and printing it off as
a warped, unrecognizable mess, something was
born.
Located at the end of a series of long, winding
concrete stairs and kept out of sight behind
doors marked ‘Keep Out’ and ‘Staff Only’,
is a lower level of the mall.
Hidden in this dark, off-limits area, that
no member of the public is permitted to access,
there is a service door, somewhere in the
southwest corner of the third subbasement.
Just taking a passing look at it, you could
easily imagine nothing all that interesting
behind it – like a power generator or a
storage room.
But if you were to push it open and venture
inside, you’d stumble upon something you
never would have expected in your wildest
dreams… or, more accurately, your most disturbing
nightmares.
Beyond that service door is a cavern, hardly
the first thing you’d assume to be secreted
away underneath a city shopping mall.
Although, if you’re into cave jumping, it
would be ill-advised to take a spelunking
adventure down there.
The entire cavern isn’t actually part of
our world, it’s an extradimensional space.
Think of it as its own little pocket universe
that has somehow become connected to ours
and can now be accessed through this doorway.
If it helps, you can even picture our universe
as a big soap bubble, with a slightly smaller
bubble attached to it.
In actuality, it’s infinitely more complicated
and looks nothing like two bubbles of different
sizes, but like we said, if it helps to picture
it that way then go right ahead.
If you were brave enough – or naïve enough
– to venture deeper into this cave and not
be put off by its walls that look like they’ve
been carved from pure limestone, then you
would have to watch your step to avoid a nasty
fall.
Within the large cave space is a deep, dark
pit, a rocky conduit in the ground, seemingly
leading down into the Earth.
But, taking a closer look, the walls of this
pit aren’t made of rock, they don’t even
match the limestone that the rest of the cavernous
room looks to be cut from.
The surface of the pit is coated in a slimy
substance, closer to something biological,
coming from a living thing rather than being
carved out of rock.
Depending on your familiarity with the texture,
you might even say this substance is not all
that far off from the appearance and feel
of human fat tissue.
Although you probably shouldn’t reach in
to try to touch it for yourself, least of
all because the walls of the pit are constantly
secreting a corrosive substance like acid,
that could easily break down your body by
its molecules, painfully burning you until
you melted down into soup.
But there’s something else down there; lots
of somethings, as a matter of fact.
And the moment you took that photo, sitting
in the safety of the booth in the mall above,
a new something found itself born into the
pit.
It looks almost exactly like you, but its
face is all wrong.
You could even say distorted, like a photograph
that didn’t quite come out right.
The abnormalities in its face could take the
form of lacerations; cuts and open wounds,
or bloody welts, like looking in a mirror
at a twisted, injured version of yourself.
Or, this imperfect copy might have growths
bulging out from its head, covering its facial
features to make it virtually unrecognizable
as a clone of you.
Then again, maybe it’ll just come out missing
everything: no eyes, mouth, nose, just a blank,
expressionless mask on a body otherwise identical
to yours.
And what does this… thing, this clone do
now that it finds itself in a pit, filled
with other writhing, imperfect copies of everyone
that’s ever sat to have their picture taken
in that photo booth?
Well, what would you do?
You would try to get out, as quickly as possible.
And that’s what it will start doing.
While you’re going about the rest of your
day, maybe stopping off at a few more stores
in the mall, or complaining to the customer
service staff about that faulty photo booth,
it’s already started climbing.
Its fingernails are digging into that fleshy
tissue that coats the walls of the pit, as
the copy drags its imperfect body upwards,
crawling over the others around it that are
trying to do the same.
There’s no telling just how many of them
are down there, how many misshapen heads and
deformed faces your clone has had to barge
past and climb over as they all pile deep
down within their hole in the ground.
And what’s the worst part of all this?
It’s not just the climb, the fact that your
copy has to fight its way out of that pit,
making the near-impossible ascent to make
it to the surface.
No, the worst part is that you have no idea
it’s happening.
You’re completely oblivious that a distorted
clone of you is raking its nails against walls
of fat tissue, clambering up from underneath
the ground.
And even more so, you have no idea what it
wants to do when it gets free and finds you…
The SCP Foundation had long since been keeping
an eye on the anomaly, that they themselves
had designated as SCP-715.
Given that the photo booth itself was connected
to the extradimensional space buried deep
below the mall, removing it isn’t really
an option.
Sure, they could easily have cordoned it off,
and put up signs saying the booth was out
of order to deter members of the public from
trying to use it.
But this was the SCP Foundation, after all,
they needed to run tests, figure out exactly
what this anomaly did and how it ticked.
Gerald Patton had been a rising star at the
Foundation, a promising researcher who had
long been proving his mettle since he first
became part of the organisation.
For a time, the higher-ups at the Foundation
had planned to attach the researcher to the
SCP-2090 project, studying a basketball player
who somehow gained anomalous powers.
However, hearing about the photo booth in
the Ohio city mall, he turned down this request
to instead join the team researching SCP-715.
Certain high-level staff of the SCP Foundation
noted this to be strange, Patton had never
turned down a promotion before, as the SCP-2090
project would have offered him better pay
and more vacation time.
In order to observe the photo booth closely
without alerting the public to their presence,
Foundation staff on site were disguised to
blend in with civilians and some posed as
retail staff employed at the mall.
Come closing time, once everyone else that
worked there or who had been shopping throughout
the day had finally left, the Foundation researchers
were free to run their tests and investigate
the anomalous photo booth.
It was the night of a routine sweep, all staff
members on site were required to test the
surrounding area for reality-warping anomalies.
The sweep was mandatory for the entire team
assigned to SCP-715, yet quite unusually,
Researcher Patton didn’t report in for the
procedure.
The higher-ups at the Foundation decided to
let the indiscretion slide though, after all,
there were a lot of personnel involved in
the process, so Patton was let off the hook.
In fact, the few disparities in Patton’s
behaviour only became more apparent when Doctor
Agatha Rights began to more closely collate
and process the files and information on the
personnel on-site.
She was the Research Head on the SCP-715 project
and quickly noticed a few things didn’t
add up about Researcher Gerald Patton.
His rejection of the offer to join the SCP-2090
project and refusal to attend a routine reality-bending
anomaly sweep might have seemed like unrelated
incidents at first.
But both would have brought the researcher
into contact with technology that the Foundation
used specifically to detect any distortions
to reality.
If he had taken the promotion, or been present
for the sweep, he too would have been within
the scope of this specialized detection equipment.
Yet, both times, he managed to avoid being
put in such a position.
What the hell was Patton hiding… and what
would show up if a detector was pointed at
him?
Doctor Rights was growing ever more suspicious
of Researcher Patton and his behavior.
However, it was when she learned he had secretly
tested the photo booth himself that she decided
to take matters into her own hands in order
to get to the bottom of what Gerald was up
to.
She had to mull it over, and think about things
cautiously.
She couldn’t confront him directly, at least
not yet.
Even the evidence she already had – that
Patton had seemingly twice avoided situations
involving the use of reality distortion detection
equipment – wasn’t enough to prove for
certain he was hiding something.
Both instances could have been caused by something
completely unrelated, Gerald could have rejected
his promotion purely because he was more interested
in SCP-715 than joining the SCP-2090 project.
And even Foundation personnel needed sick
days, or skipped work because of a hangover
without telling anyone, which could explain
why he was absent during the sweep of the
mall.
But Agatha wasn’t convinced, it felt like
the two instances lined up too closely, they
felt far too similar to be an utterly random
coincidence.
Even if Gerald wasn’t up to anything dangerous,
the only way to know for sure was to observe
him, but without drawing attention to it.
He’d deny anything, act completely differently,
maybe even flat out lie if he knew someone
was listening or watching.
Agatha was forced to think in a way that was
as calculated as she was certain Gerald had
been.
His quarters were located in a secluded part
of the subbasement, a level above where the
fleshy pit could be found.
Almost all the Foundation personnel assigned
to SCP-715 slept somewhere on-site, their
presence there masked from other ordinary
mall employees.
Taking care not to be detected, they had installed
doors with a key card system, meaning only
members of their own staff could access the
living quarters under the mall.
If any civilians happened to stumble upon
the Foundation and discover them, then all
it took was the careful application of amnestics
to ensure that they wouldn’t remember a
thing.
Beeping her key card at the door, Agatha slipped
in to the living area.
It mostly consisted of a narrow corridor,
with a row of doors either side.
Behind each one was a cramped room, each only
big enough for one person, a bunk to sleep
in and a sink with a mirror above it.
Gerald’s room was the furthest from the
entrance, right down at the end of the corridor,
as far from everyone else as he could get.
Although, it also meant if he came back from
testing early, then he’d be more likely
to catch Agatha leaving his room and walking
back along the row.
It would be hard to come up with an excuse
as to what she was doing anywhere near his
quarters, especially as her room was behind
the very first door, right next to the entrance.
All this was rushing through Doctor Rights’
mind as she squeezed into Patton’s room;
in actual fact, the interior space of them
was so limited they were even smaller than
most ship cabins.
Her hand had been clasped around the handle
of a metal case which she set down on Gerald’s
empty bed.
Unclasping the clips that held it closed,
Agatha opened up the case and took out what
was held inside the inner layer of protective
foam.
It was a Fulmann-Breaker Anomalous Optical
Enhancement device, a piece of the specialized
apparatus that the Foundation’s researchers
used to record and identify any person or
object that might be exhibiting anomalous
properties.
It utilized state-of-the-art optical enhancement
technology and could be used to detect whether
a subject was causing any distortion to the
reality around it, by accessing visual spectrums
that were normally imperceivable to the naked
human eye; or sometimes even unobservable
in this dimension.
Agatha looked around the tiny cabin; given
the limited space, she was also short on options
as to where she could hide the device without
it being easily noticed.
It was imperative that Researcher Patton had
no idea he was under observation.
Doctor Rights looked over to the sink in the
corner: the mirror just above it.
Sure, it was a tactic taken straight out of
the big book of spy novel clichés, but it
would work.
The advanced spectrum capabilities of the
Optical Enhancement device would be able to
record Patton through the glass.
Luckily, the entire living quarters had been
pretty hastily built, which meant it took
little effort for Agatha to loosen the screws
holding the mirror in place.
But that’s when she heard the distinctive
beep of the door to the living quarters, followed
by gradual footsteps getting closer and closer.
It might not have been Gerald, but there was
an equal chance that it could have been.
Acting as fast as she could, Agatha placed
the Optical Enhancement device on the wall
and covered it with the mirror, frantically
trying to screw it back into place as quick
as she could.
The echoing noise of someone approaching sounded
as if they were almost right outside the cabin
door by the time Doctor Rights had tightened
the screws enough to keep the mirror in place.
Giving a quick final scan of the room, making
sure nothing looked too conspicuous, she grabbed
the empty case and smoothed out the duvet
where it had been laying, leaving no trace
that she had ever been there.
Her heart already racing, it almost exploded
right out of her chest as she slipped back
out of the door to Patton’s cabin…
only to see him walking down the narrow corridor
directly towards his room, towards her.the
nearest trash can.
“Doctor Rights,” Gerald greeted with a
staged smile, though the suspicion on his
face was so unmistakable that that it could
probably show up clearly on camera.
“Something I can help you with?”
“Patton,” Agatha gave a polite nod back
to the researcher; lifting the case behind
her back.
The one upside of the tight corridor was that
Patton was so close to her he couldn’t see
what she was hiding; the obvious downside
being he might be close enough to clock Doctor
Rights’ suspicion of him.
“Did you need something?”
Patton chuckled.
“Sorry, it’s just…
what were you doing in my quarters?”
Her heart was still racing, desperately trying
to form a plausible excuse somewhere in her
mind.
Agatha’s free hand reached into her pocket,
something brushing against her fingertips;
it would have to do.
“You dropped this!”
she exclaimed, pulling out a twenty-dollar
bill and handing it to Gerald, a small price
to pay to keep her subterfuge.
“Earlier on, in the mall, near SCP-715,
I saw it fall out of your pocket.
I had other matters to attend to down at…
anyway, I wanted to make sure you got it back.”
“Oh, thank you,” Gerald blinked in surprise,
taking the money.
As she squeezed past him and walked out of
the living quarters, Agatha could barely stop
her hands from shaking.
Although, those tremors of nerves would become
the trembling of absolute horror when she
saw the footage that the Optical Enhancement
device collected.
Patton was one of the creatures from the pit.
It didn’t seem possible; he didn’t even
have clearance to know about the pit, and
any of the clones – or SCP-715-As – that
managed to claw their way up to the surface
were immediately terminated by on-site security
– the instances becoming known as SCP-715-Bs
if they made it that far.
Yet, somehow Patton, or whatever he really
was, had made it through undetected.
But that was far from the worst discovery
Doctor Rights would make.
She used a number of the same Anomalous Optical
Enhancement devices to observe the SCP-715-A
creatures within the pit only to find that
she and the other researchers had made a grave
mistake.
The SCP-715-As… they were all humans.
What the Foundation had initially thought
were the distorted, imperfect clone copies
of everyone who had used the SCP-715 photo
booth, were actually the originals.
They had been trying to climb back up because
they wanted to come home, their places taken
by SCP-715-Bs.
But none of those people – now twisted,
disfigured, and unrecognizable – were able
to explain to the Foundation who they were.
And they’d been shot, left to fall back
into the pit and die.
Acting fast, Doctor Rights updated the classification
of SCP-715 to Keter, although this was later
rescinded back to ‘Safe’.
The creature that looked like Researcher Patton
was apprehended and brought in for interrogation.
After learning the truth behind SCP-715, the
photo booth was secured and locked up permanently.
But, as of now, the project investigating
SCP-715 has been put on hold.
No-one at the Foundation wants to admit the
mistake, that they now have an extradimensional
pit full of innocent, distorted people…
or that they have no idea where all their
body-swapped counterparts are…
Now go and check out “SCP-1733 SEASON OPENER”
for another tale of another anomaly caught
on film – this time, it’s a basketball
that you won’t be able to stop watching…
Or, if you’d rather further your investigation
into some more paranormal photography, then
we’ve got just the video for you: “SCP-978
THE DESIRE CAMERA”!